[Musique]
est venu dans mon équipe
nous devons vous remercier au début et
lourd et compté mais plus tard
mieux vaut arrêter de faire ça parce que comme
ils m'ont donné des cauchemars
Oui
arrêter
comme en 2021
ni les gens le terrain ne s'approche de moi
Thriller en francais
et que pas beaucoup d'environ 46 au plus
et moi qui le même en attendant en toi pas
étrange ce n'est pas nécessaire
souhaitant être le numéro 7 sont exquis
pas méchant
Eh bien, comme tout ce dont vous parlez
mais
[Applaudissements]
Oui
le chacal
sucre extrême
[Musique]
année et devant le pp en attente de 646 et
transporteur
que se passe-t-il que les gens qui sont
ils se consacrent à tuer des gens pour de l'argent beaucoup
Parfois nous ne nous connaissons pas
des gens qui nous embauchent bien
nous demandons pourquoi nous allons tuer le
personne comme les autres
Travaillons, obtenons l'argent que nous
donner l'ordre de travail et nous donner
nous respectons le dvk maxillaire
[Musique]
Oh
à 15 ans
comme la formation militaire c'était un
cours de base auquel j'ai appris le
port d'armes défense balistique
personnel
premiers secours et tout
exiger non mais après avoir quitté un
armée et est
et quand un peu au chômage pendant un certain temps et
errant d'avant en arrière et j'ai commencé à
voler dans les cambriolages tu tues des gens
parce qu'ils s'opposent à l'assaut alors celui-ci
il a tué des gens et puis pour n'avoir rien volé
plus jusqu'à ce qu'une personne vienne me voir
m'ont donné l'opportunité m'ont dit qu'ils voulaient
faire déjà pour tuer une personne et je
rendu plus facile d'atteindre et de tuer le
personne qui allait voler le et ça m'a été fait
plus facile de cette façon c'est pourquoi j'ai commencé à saisir
ce type de travail
pour
J'apporte 19 millimètres par an et virtuel
sont en millimètres avec un chargeur
approvisionné
[Musique]
il s'appelle
nouveau n'est pas parce qu'il a déjà été utilisé
plusieurs fois mais il a l'air neuf
et il y a celui de chez moi pour les boulots qui
utiliser des branches différentes car celle-ci
Cela dépend du travail, l'un des
arme à feu puis voté contre jeter une arme à feu
[Musique]
écrit
ligne de constructeurs d'informations
la personne qui m'embauche lui donne un
feuille avec la photo de la personne
adressez votre adresse de travail dans le
semaine être une tournée qui prend du temps
vous dit que vous savez que vous êtes ici
adresse votre adresse est travail et dans
le chemin de la pointe et vous le faites ou où il se trouve
tu peux sortir c'est mieux et il y en a
les personnes qui ne sont pas spécifiquement de
césar décrit essentiellement assis un
bureau et quelques arrêts vont le tuer là
à la maison ou la nuit allez-y ils disent
et là vous le remarquerez plusieurs fois comme
les gens veulent sentir comme ça
la tête ou l'école être facile n'importe
chose
Il est très grand
au soleil prospérer la vie
le dire strict n'a presque pas été utilisé
c'est toujours un pistolet et un couteau
Je suis je suis radical nous sommes un nouveau couteau
Plusieurs fois, je ferais un vœu au saman
couteau mordant la vérité qui se moquait
ils nato
comme droit au coeur mais en plus
c'est plus facile de leur trancher la gorge
tu sais combien de personnes avec des filles mais
Je ne saurais dire les principes et lourds et
Je les ai comptés mais après le
mieux que de faire ça parce que comme
ça m'a donné des cauchemars mais c'est
dans le comptage des mérisations
comme 2021
peut ferme de narcos divisions
Je ne sais pas pour mon opinion d'alors avec un
l'école pour que ceux qui commencent
va chercher des ombres à partir de là
commencer à faire votre travail
aussi bien de nombreux programmes et tout
ceux-là le prennent de la vraie vie
mais ils ne révèlent jamais la vérité alors
vraiment brut comme il est
ni moi ni les gens les beatles
[Musique]
beaucoup plus
nuit dans deux de plus
et moi qui équivaut au total à 30 non
ils ne sont pas nécessaires
le type
c'est comme si tout allait mal non pas parce que
marque de tuer des gens dans la rue
vrai pour l'argent mais c'est que beaucoup
Parfois, nous n'avons pas le choix et si je
recevoir dans le meurtre de rob behring
les gens ce qui par inadvertance et sans le savoir
assister à un but aurait peut-être mieux
Un objectif
quelle est la vie humaine
donc c'est moins cher que ce qui a été payé
été 100 mille pesos et il y a déjà quelques
que 300 250 mille pesos selon ce
client mais moins de 100 pas parce que oui
que votre commission lui et ce que moi
me correspond
webber wifi depuis les camps act
parce que c'est
à un journaliste
parce qu'ils attrapent toujours ceux qui
ils tuent des journalistes avec des civils
de nombreux canaux dans la rue à pied
se promener et en tuer un et pour une grande partie de
que votre proche ou tout le monde veut
enquêter et ne rien faire qu'ils ne puissent pas faire
rien que la compagnie d'un rapport du
auteur d'un compagnon est fait
c'est qu'il t'a comblé de quelqu'un parce que
c'était avec une personne de chinautla che à
un congé de maladie la personne qui
ils venaient
parce que c'est beaucoup d'argent qu'ils paient pour un
journaliste la vérité ici ils donnent 300 jusqu'à
500 mille pesos et ils se partagent le canal
police de la mode express ou lune comme ça
prix de la minijupe à imprimé paul tucker
sauvage sans car ils ne trouveront pas
de toute façon jusqu'à ce que j'ai celui-là
théorie que je ne le fais pas parce qu'ils vont
trouve qu'ils vont m'attraper ce n'est pas pour ça
Je dis le document ou charles pas pour le
hommes et adultes parce que
intello
Tu t'en fous d'en tuer un
personne mais je ne sais pas n'en a jamais tué un
femme et rien que personne ne lui tire dessus et
ce ne sont pas deux femmes dites métiers pénibles dans
de la fermeture de la famille ni ne sont
J'ai un emploi et je travaille dans un
fabrique de meubles ou menuisier
chauffeur oui oui j'ai de la famille j'en ai un
femme et moi avons un fils de 22 ans dit
la famille sait ce que tu es en une nuit
bouchon en zinc personne ne sait où
autour sait ce que je fais
chercher nous vivons et nous habillons mais non
parce que ce n'est pas si souvent qu'ils le sont
en bonne santé avant les problèmes et
tout l'argent sale de tout mais bon
mais tu crampes c'est comme ça
vous je suis de toute façon dans le souhait ce n'est pas quoi
se passe, c'est que je garde cet argent dans
deux comptes trois comptes ce nom n'existe pas
il est né donc il est dispersé
dans différents endroits et de là je vais
saisir au besoin
Je peux dire que je vis calmement car
C'est dans l'armée de plus de saveur et il y a
et ils n'apprennent pas à obéir
commandes et vous le prenez déjà avec une commande et
votre sujet n'était pas qu'il a décidé de tuer
la personne mais la personne qui a envoyé
la tuer, je suis un peu calme parce que je
ne pas prendre la décision et signifiait que
l'échec chez les gens d'austin ce qui se passe est
que quand c'est difficile c'est au début
les premières fois que tu te sens plus comme ça
nerveux qu'après comme tout tu partes
s'habituer à
Je suis huguet et je suis là et c'est comme tout
quelque chose qui a été donné petit à petit parce que
la vérité je n'ai pas choisi pour moins
plusieurs fois poussé à ce que je suis
parfois le désespoir manque
d'argent et
je viens watts je n'ai pas
ne regrette rien
Ce qui est arrivé est arrivé
de ma vie après la vie, c'était quelque chose comme ça
si nous devons continuer à installer non
parce que cela
[Musique]
Je vais tout sortir, juste le sortir pour travailler à
maximum en cycle plus ou moins c'est l'idée
del fin si ira à une sorte d'oiseaux
homme de glace j'aime peut-être
dire non comme il est dit si nous respirons
si Dieu nous pardonne tout le moi
Je regrette du fond du coeur dès que possible
mourir peut-être que je n'irai pas au paradis
pour
[Musique]